first of all I very much like the shirt
that you're wearing it's cool it look
it's got I want to describe it to people
it's got like epaulettes on the side but
then uh beautiful like pink pony hair
hanging down from the epaulettes
gorgeous yes what is this you're wearing
so this is actually my work uniform this
is a boiler suit so it's a full uh you
know all right don't Point your butt
power Zeus I've gotten in trouble asking
people to do that online
yeah but oh my goodness but um no so
it's you're wearing yeah it's a full we
would call it maybe a bodysuit or
jumpsuit jumpsuit yeah we call it a
boiler suit so it looks like yeah you're
here to repair a boiler but you also
having to be an admiral in the French
navy uh yeah it's incredible the French
tickler thank you so much okay you take
it easy buddy boys I like the pom-poms
yeah the pom-poms look good thank you so
much yeah it is amazing what you can do
with um a glue gun so yeah my um my
official job title is and this can
really get lost in translation but I'm a
crack mechanic so my job is to I'm not
spelled that spelled c-r-a-i-c so
basically my job is to go into spaces
and help loosen up people's joints and
help them unleash their inner crack but
yeah I wear a boiler suit because you
know it's it's dirty business I have to
uh yeah help people to have a good time
are you a masseuse then I'm really
trying to understand no no I'll tell you
you're a chiropractor yeah yeah no what
uh what I'll tell you honestly is um I'm
I'm a wedding DJ and
if you are so Irish because there's so
much deflection going on that I don't
know what you're talking about and this
happens and whenever I talk to anyone in
my family well I help boosting people's
backs up do you really yeah I'm a
wedding
then you're like no of course I don't do
that yeah
so what you're saying is you're oh when
you say you loosen people up you mean
you entertain them no so what I meant is
uh I'm a wedding DJ and my job title is
I'm a crack mechanic because I have a an
events company called the sing-along
social and basically we uh do singing
parties for people who can't sing so
that's our whole vibe we love to uh pop
up at festivals and weddings as well and
music festivals uh all around Ireland
and Europe and but basically when I
first started
um DJing I have to say that I wasn't the
best DJ and so what I decided to do was
I decided to
um distract people and deflect in my
very Irish Way by bringing props and
bringing the kind of songs to life so I
would build uh I'd make signs
um bring kind of like inflatable guitars
for different moments or
um basically yeah
um trying to animate the songs
if I completely understand with what
you're talking about because throughout
my career I've tried to deflect and
distract from my lack of ability using
wild gesticulations body motions uh
pumped up hair and lots of props and
it's worked fine I've gotten away with
it but I know exactly what you're
talking about Governor Brian needs a
friend is brought to you by T-Mobile
from listening to your favorite podcast
while driving cross-country to listening
at home T-Mobile helps you stay
connected I wonder what people's
favorite podcast is oh I've got some
ideas actually it's one idea yeah you'll
figure it out T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can
have seamless video calling oh that's
good streaming your favorite podcast I'm
not gonna say which one it is yeah
downloading apps games boy you know what
a gamer I am you're such a gamer play
starbursters yeah or realm of Thanos
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at tmobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA speed test intelligence
data for q1 2023 c5g device coverage and
access details at t-mobile.com
I'm curious you say that you lead people
in sing-alongs and your specialty is
helping people who can't sing I always
think of the Irish as being able to sing
well is that not I know that's a huge
generalization but are there many people
in Ireland who don't know how to sing so
of course uh even even on our most
talented Island there are people who
can't sing
um but what's amazing to me is you can
get a hundred terrible singers into a
room and when they all start singing
together it sounds really beautiful I
don't know what that is but like the
individual is it's called alcohol
that's your perception after a few
drinks basically it's for people
um you know I I actually love singing um
but I I've always kind of struggled a
little bit with uh remembering lyrics
okay uh also and I also struggle with
them a bit of performance like feeling a
bit frightened of being on stage
um singing specific typically so then
those kind of things they I'm not great
at being on time so those things all
stop me from joining a choir so uh so
then I had no real outlet for singing
and
um this my event the sing-along social
it it happened totally by accident I
wanted to invite some friends over to my
house for brunch to listen to
um Jagged Little Pill by Alanis
Morissette the whole way through it was
like the 28 year it was about eight
years ago the 20-year anniversary I was
like let's just like come around press
play see what happens and then basically
the guesses got a bit big and I called a
friend who has a pub and said you know
let's why don't we just do it in the pub
and he said yeah why don't you put it up
on Facebook like maybe a couple of
people want to come and buy the next
like a thousand people wanted to come
and we had to like create tickets and
stuff and it was just like this
hilarious night where
um we just press played on the album it
just like started it was like it was
like do last dress you out and literally
like everyone in the world
like amazing screaming good for you this
sounds like you have a great business
going and you're bringing a lot of joy
to people now
do you think that I would fit into your
organization at all
I'm being honest I would
I would
delighted to see you at one of our
events all three of you and the whole
team the whole amazing team
I'm a terrible singer
that would be perfect for you so the
only thing so I I think um what I liked
is what we like to do is what all the
crack mechanics do is that c-r-a-i-c and
I'm sorry I didn't explain that very
well
um but they so we we like to sometimes
we create moments for people like um we
love to turn people into boy bands and
we'll like give them like big boy band
white shirts and then we'll get them to
sit down and then we'll like count to
three for them to stand up but a key
change that's really fun
um but I think Conan for you there's a
moment that I might get you involved in
um which would be there's uh we love
playing like Don't Stop Me Now by Queen
and there's a bit where it's like don't
stop me don't stop me and then there's a
guitar there's like a shredding guitar
solo after it and I would love to like
get you like give you a guitar for that
moment and just let you like an
inflatable guitar which I feel like Oh I
thought it was a right no no I'm
actually much better on an inflatable
guitar okay
so um you don't see any singing role for
me in this group
I'm I mean it's just
it's not you it's it's us excuse me it's
not what are you talking about do you
want to hear a little something I got
for you right now you want to hear a
little they want you to come to Ireland
to play with a toy
yes that would be great you would love
that you want me to come to Ireland to
pretend to strum a blow up guitar at the
very moment at the very for a brief
moment you can play a real good can I
just say something easy I'm a terrific
singer in the old Irish style and you're
missing out yeah let's hear something I
know it's a young boy in Killarney so
many years ago the party me Mom would
sing a lullaby so you can do funerals in
tune so sweet handle so sweet hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
no just do you remember your interview
with John Lithgow and you sang uh
earnestly then you sang uh authentically
and and it was so beautiful it really
really really really was it was nice it
was just uh I was happy for you that you
thought you got to sing that way and I
suppose I related to it a bit um
obviously we're on a slightly different
scale of uh what we're doing but I don't
think so much
I Think You Are My Doppelganger in so
many ways yeah we are not on different
levels at all
I'm proud to be yeah but just that you
know you have it's a beautiful thing to
sing with loads of people but it can
feel a bit inaccessible if you're not
talented or if you're afraid and to be
able to just get into your room and just
like Roar along to yeah Brittany Beyonce
Whitney Shania and like so I bring a lot
of like those people with me so this is
Shania
um oh I know I have the same cut out at
home oh God exactly
it's like a what three foot tall cut out
of Shania Twain's head just her head
yeah yeah
um um you know I know what's very nice
about what you're doing uh IFA is it is
so many people limit themselves because
they think you know I'm I'm not an
expert at this or I don't do this well
and uh as and and singing and comedy
both of those things are things that
everyone should you know should plant
both feet and go for it and just have a
good time that's what it's about
you know it's not about I mean in my
case it was for many years if I don't do
it correctly I'll be murdered but
I'm so glad you're doing that for people
that's a that's a nice that's a nice
gift you're giving people oh no it's a
it is a gift uh that I get to receive
because um it happened by accident kind
of I accidentally created my dream job
and hey it's gotten FIFA I know exactly
what you're talking about I'm serious I
I accidentally created my nightmare job
I know
this guy Connor Brian sure I'll give it
a shot uh how mean could he be
um
they're microphones he wouldn't truly be
cruel to me when microphones are going